[Applause]
with all the excitement surrounding the
2008 election it might be surprising to
learn that only fifty six point nine
percent of eligible citizens a little
over at the population turned out to
vote that year that's pretty bad but at
least it was a few points better than
2012 this kind of voter turnout puts us
pretty low on the list of developed
countries which is not something to be
proud of but it also means that voter
mobilization efforts have the potential
to yield massive results I mean for
example Romney only lost to Obama by
five million votes last time it's a
pretty small number compared to the 112
million still up for grabs they get out
the vote campaigns come in a few
different varieties the most inane and
probably the least effective is that
kind where Leonardo DiCaprio and a
laundry list of other celebrities
command you to vote from the TV
I mean seriously after all this after
this whole video if you're not gonna
vote I don't even know what to say D
anymore Wow Leo that that really hurts
even self-aware and comedic campaigns in
this Fame like the one Joss Whedon made
earlier this year likely don't move the
needle all that much because they rely
on old-fashioned techniques namely a
handful of righteous messages that
include things like it's your
responsibility to vote or your voice
won't be heard otherwise or it's a
historic and or a really really close
election while these are all really good
reasons to vote they all operate under
the assumption of a behavioral theory
called rational self-interest for
decades and decades people assume that
if social norms about voting were
heavily reinforced like they are in
those ads then people would just comply
to satisfy their sense of civic duty
unfortunately when put to the test these
techniques came up way short in a
landmark 2008 paper from Gerber green
and Larimer extensive studies found that
theories based on rational
self-interested behavior generally
failed to predict significant turnout
this goes for celebrities talking to you
through the TV or online as well as
phone banks Direct Mail or door-to-door
canvassing the problem is that plenty of
we'll tell you they're gonna vote but
don't actually do so when the time comes
but behavioral research can offer us
some tricks to help studies show for
example that if you ask people about
their specific plan ask them where
they're voting or how they're going to
get there
you could double or triple your
effectiveness also campaigners often
tell people that every vote counts more
when there's a low turnout so their vote
is extra important but the research
shows that people are more likely to
vote if they think there's going to be a
high turnout in other words if everyone
else is doing it - okay but what if you
really wanted to boost if Oh is there
anything that would motivate people in a
really big way well let's go back to
that paper from Gerber Crain and Larimer
because I think it's really fascinating
what they did they basically conducted a
large-scale field experiment where they
mailed out letters to four different
groups of people the first was a
standard campaign mailer that said do
your civic duty vote basically like
those commercials who were looking at
the second informed people that they
would be confidentially studying voter
turnout for the election now let me just
pause here to say something that you may
not know in America everyone's voting
record is public now don't freak out
because you can't find out who people
voted for only if they voted or not in
fact in the third mailer the researchers
did just that they mail people their own
voting record from the past two
elections looks like Robert Wayne wasn't
able to make it out there in 2004 in the
fourth mailer this is where it gets
really interesting takes it one step
further not only did they send out
people's voting records but they also
included the voting records of their
neighbor so that everyone could see who
voted and who did it
now while the turnout of the first group
the group who got the regular mayor
raised one point eight percentage points
turnout in the last group increased by
eight point one percentage points which
is a huge increase and it makes sense I
wouldn't want to be the only one on my
block who didn't vote now I'm not saying
this is the right thing to do it's
probably not but imagine if facebook
told you that it was instituting a flare
on your app
Tarr after the election based on the
public record that simply said voted
something that you didn't have to put up
if you didn't want to but couldn't put
up if you did info or imagine if it just
put a big didn't vote after someone
saying I bet you'd see a pretty
significant increase in voting across
the board now I realize that shaming
people is probably not the best
motivator and researchers found that
this method did receive a fair amount of
backlash but it is interesting to think
about voter participation is something
that concerns all of us because only
about half of Americans vote every four
years and far fewer at local elections
in between I mean just imagine if the
over 100 million people who don't vote
could be motivated to do so the
political landscape that everyone seems
to be so tired of could be totally
transformed but you know don't take it
from me I mean seriously after all this
after this whole video if you're not
gonna really know what to say Dee
anymore there is a new nerdwriter video
every Wednesday so click that box right
there you know what forget about just
can you see this
is Florence Italy and the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen I'm here with my
parents for today I'm sorry the videos
have been late I just there's been so
much here Italy it's been so amazing
anyway I have to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this video they make sleek
intuitive websites if you sign up for a
year you get a free domain name at
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter you get 10% off your
first breath don't make a Squarespace
website but look at this amazing